my name is Jeff Jackson and the reason I
came on the extravaganza was because the
IRAs had my retirement coming up and I
wanted not only something to do but
something to boost my income and having
plenty of time available I thought it
sounded a good idea we have two
properties in London a two bedroom flat
in Bexleyheath and a five bedroom house
which was a lease option in Gravesend
since doing Samuels workshop we've
decided that we're going to change our
strategy get rid of the properties in
London and moved to the Midlands where
we could probably get three times the
number of properties for what we've got
in London so that was a real eye-opener
for us I came to the deal finding
extravaganza
worked on where my patch was going to be
settled on Doncaster and Liverpool and
immediately made a sale in both property
in both areas and which paid for the
deal finding extravaganza really in the
first all weeks and very little works
and now I'm planning on going forward
and trying my target is four to five
properties a month and I feel quite easy
that I will achieve that I would
recommend the dill funny extravaganza to
anybody it's opened my eyes on how fund
investment properties in the Midlands
there are strict formulas that Jews
adhere to you pretty much can't go wrong
if you stick to those formulas it's
changed my strategy on property
investment in the UK and I would
thoroughly recommend it to anybody who's
contemplating doing the course